>> Jesse: KYY
[Cheering; applause] TRYING TO
EVEN THINGS UP FOR D DLSKI IN O.
STRETCHES IT OUT AND ITAUTIFUL E
SHOOTOUT.
AND FITTING.
I THINK PUCK.
TKACHUK BRINGS IT IN.
OFF THE BOARDS FOR LOOSE PUCK R.
WATCH HIM JUST IN THE GAME.
STOPPED BY SHESTYORKIN!
HE GOT IT WITH THE GLOVE THAT, D
NOT GO INTO THE CORNER OND
CERNAK PUTS IT TOARNER.
MARNER SHOOTS OFF THE LEG OF
CIRELLI.RACING UP IS LETANG.
CARTER WITH A GOAL, THE
FANS ARE GOING TO BE RATHER
WINNER
IT IS WORKING OUT.
>> WELL JACK, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU COULD HAVEE AND A
GREAT GAME WINNER
HE IS RUN OVER BY LETANG AND
IT'S A LONG BREAK AWAY OTHER WAY
.
DENIED.
>> ANOTHER BRICK IN THE WALL.
HE SCORES, MAN HE M M SEEING HI
-GOT BY THE PAD OF JAMES REIMER.
SEVERSON, SHOOTING, HE SCORES.
BACK HAND, FOREHAND, RIGHT UP
TOP UNDER THE BAR.ME BACK
AND FORTH WITH THE 3 ON 3.
IAFALLO, HE WAS ABLE TO MAKE HIS
OWN CHANCE TO THE PLAY, BUT THEN
MONTREAL GETS THE COUNTER ATTACK
THE OTHER WAY WITH IAFALLO
PLAYING D.
BUT LOOK AT THAT.
CAL PETERSONKS OUT.
1:35 LEFT IN OVERTIME.
KEMPE RACES IN.
KEMPE AROUND THE NET.
LOOKING FOR A LANE, KEMPE DRIFTS
OUT TO THE BLUE LINE.
>> Jim: GOT A FORWARD HERE.
CONNOR WAITINGD SLOWING IT DOWN
THE GLOVE.Y GET THE EXTRA POINT
WINNING IN A A THE SHOT.
PUT IN FRONT, LETANG.
GREAT SAVE A LANE.
MATHESON ON FOR THE SHOOTOUT.
>> AS HAS BEENHAVE A
CHANCE TO END  MILANO,
PETTERSSON BLOCKING IT,SDALE
INTO THE ZONE.
SHOT, SAVE, REBOUND,
AND BECAUSE IT WAS STANDING ON
END, HORVAT SHOOTING IT WIDE
YES!   CARTER STARTS HIS OFFICEN
AROUND FOUR HE ATTEMPTED.
HE CAN SAVE THE THE NET,
AND OUT TO THE WING.ND THEN PUL
MATTHEWS.E REALLY
AUSTON MATTHEWS IN THE BREAK.
>> All: SOOOOUUUPPPPP!KYLINGTON.
MOVES IN AND SHOOTS.ELL IS ABOUE
FEET OUT OF THE NET SWIMMING
AROUND AND HE ENDS UP GETTING
LEFT PAD ON IT.
IT'S BEEN A GREAT OVERTIME
MY STICK IS BROKEN.
HE NEEDS A NEW TWIG.
SO THE
HE WAS ONE ON ONE ON THE
>> JUST OUTSTANDING GOALTENDING
HERE.
THAT IS WHAT
AND DOWN THE ICE IT GOES.
>> AND THE LIGHTNING WIN IT.
AND HE CAN REALLY SNIPE
KEN: AND HE SCORED TWO FROM
AND THE PASS FOR ZIBANEJAD
.
>> Sam: 1-1 IN THE IN.
>> Sam: AND NOW, ARTEMI PANARIN
MUST IT'S UP TO STROME.
HE MUST SCORE TO KEEP THE
RANGERS ALIVE.
STROME FAKES, ,
LOOKED LIKE HE COMMITTED TO
ZONE.
AND HE KNEW IT.
WATCH THE RIGHT LEG.
>> Joe: HE GOT IN AND BERNIER
GIBSON.
NOW UNDER A HOT.
ZEGRAS PUTS THE DUCKS TO THE
WIN COLUTHAT WHEN IN
INTENDED TARGET.
HE WAS LOOKING FOR GIROUX IN
HI
ALREADY FIGURED VASILEVSKIY.
>> Brian: MAYBE HE LOST CONTROL
OF THIS A LITTLE BIT.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE OFF AND
CHYCHRUN AGAIN WITH IT BRING IT.
WEDGWOOD.
JAKOBTHE STICK WAY UPFRONT.
THE STICK OUT, STICK OUT,
>> PACK YOUR BAGS UP, JEFF.
IS THAT FINAL?
OF COURSE IT WAS. FAKES, FAKES,.
RIGHT OVER THE
EDMONTON 2-WINNIPE THE OTHER WA
ANZE KOPITAR IS IN,PORTUNITY.  D
THEY GET ONE POINT THEY DON'TE
REINHART.
LOOK OUT . THE BREAKAWAY CHANCE
AARON EKBLAD CONTROLLED IT. TWO
TO WIN THE GAME.
KANE.
KANE. . OUR
WITH TANEV WITH
GAUDREAU, JOINING LATE,
GETS A SHOT
>> Rick: SIDNEY CROSBY ON
MARKSTROM.
HE WILL SWING OUTREE.
GAUDREAU,,LETANG HAS TO
SCORE, AND A MARKSTROM SAVE WILL
WIN IT, LETANG, HE S S ON TO
ROUND FOUR.
>> Kelly: :
>> Rick: THE SEVENTH ROUND,
MIKAEL BACKLUND, UP NEXT.
MARKSTROM, A SAVE ONON
>> A.J.: HE'S LOW.
HE LEFT A LOT THERE.
>> John: -- WOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED IFOLD PADDLE ON THE
BLADE OF
FOWLER OFF THEAY OUT TO WATCH I.
AND HE
GOAL LINE.
LOOK HOW DEEP QUICK IS.
THAT PUCK JUST